Lori Loughlin the see how she balances  her own full house how do you balance  being a mom having fuller house having  your show that's on hallmark you know  it's some one day at a time  I'm constantly writing notes to myself  things definitely slip through the  cracks you face time with the girls a  lot I do face time at night with the  girls I do my girls now 16 and 17 no  even when I'm home I don't put them to  bed they're up way later than I am like  a nine o'clock on my exactly they need  to tuck me in  talk about a fuller house the 51 year  old married mom of two still finding  time to rock those ABS while bouncing  between LA and Vancouver for her  hallmark show when calls the heart the  season finale is this Sunday it's so so  good and Ben and Brooke Shields is guest  starring on our finale to look in the  flesh and I've known her since we were  11 years old we started we started  modeling together so yeah such a treat  to work with her